now I thrill I think for all of us  to present the award for the best actor  an Oscar winner back in Hollywood for  the first time in three years one of the  screens first lady's and past president  of the Academy Miss Betty Davis  thank you and I think you know that I  feel just great to be back working again  and now I know that you're as anxious as  I am to find out what actor has won the  Oscar for the best performance of this  year have I a little spread to tempt you  all with this the winner is Marlon  Brando  it's much heavier than I imagined yeah  dosa had a something to say and I can't  remember what I was going to say that  I'll lie to me I don't think that ever  in my life have have so many people been  so directly responsible for my being so  very very glad it's a wonderful moment  in a rare one and I'm certainly indebted  thank you